- Tonight, we're celebrating
the timeless values
that President Kennedy lived by
and that have made America
the indispensable nation.
Courage, patriotism,
justice, innovation, service,
and the commitment to building
a more peaceful world.
As his family, we're
proud of what he stood for
and its continuing power.
Tonight, we're honored by the presence
of so many public servants who
live these values every day.
This award celebrates
the indispensable quality
in public life that my
father most admired.
The courage to risk your
career to do what's right.
That may mean standing
for the national interest
when others are willing to trade it away
for personal or local benefit.
It may mean reaching
out to work with others
to benefit the common good
when you could score points
by criticizing them instead.
Over the years, we've
honored elected officials
at all levels of government
from both sides of the aisle.
They have reaffirmed our faith
in principled public service
and set a standard by which
future leaders can be measured.
Our winners have shown us that we need
to reward courage in our leaders
and require it in ourselves.
Today, when many doubt the
integrity of our elected officials,
this award is more important than ever.
Many of you, here in this room,
cast your first vote
for President Kennedy.
You've told me how he changed your lives.
And, together, you changed this country.
Tonight, we present the
Profile in Courage Award
to President Obama,
who had the same impact
on another generation.
Inspiring us, our
children, and grandchildren
to change the world.
On a personal note, I want to thank you
for giving me the chance to serve.
In Japan, I saw, firsthand,
what American leadership
means to the world.
I saw the power of our commitment
to a rules-based international order
in lifting people out of poverty.
I saw the hope and
idealism of young people
inspired by American
innovation and possibility.